[Music]
to the latest on troubled singer and
Demi lavato yeah Nancy just three days
after she suffered that shocking drug
overdose new details have just surfaced
could gather any medication
authorities have released the 911 call
made from Demi's home Tuesday morning
the caller wanted paramedics to arrive
quietly it's unclear if the singer who
was hospitalized at cedars-sinai Medical
Center will be checking into rehab a
source tells us quote her family has
realized they are not out of the woods
yet
and are very concerned that she doesn't
see the severity of her issues and are
worried because she thinks she can
control her addiction looking back there
were a lot of red flags that Dimi was
struggling sometimes I will still
struggle with past behaviors kind of and
cravings creeping in the singer recently
severed ties with her support team
including her longtime sober coach Mike
Beier at the time Demi made a decision
to get sober she literally said I'll do
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Applause]